benvenuti inserita astori oggi iniziamo
il video in una stanza diversa perché
siamo nella cameretta della gattina
nella faremo vedere in questi giorni
perché dobbiamo un po modificare un po
arredarla mettere vari giochini e varie
cose poi lasciato un mi piace qui per
vedere il video attivate da campanelline
agosto sopra non perde bloom nel
frattempo l'inter cercando di mangiare i
cagnolini disdegnate nella mia maglietta
mese se berlino ii nella sua cuccetta
che la osserva piano piano berlino si
sta abituale sempre di più piano piano
però poteva la giusta fame modo strano e
penso che questa questa dovrebbe essere
la mia sorellina
oggi porteremo circe in giardino ed
esplorerà il giardino per la prima volta
come reagirà secondo voi renderli
permettetevi comodi e andiamo in
giardino via il ciclo fuori in giardino
lei sta osservando tutto è molto
incuriosita facciamole esplorare tutto
andiamo
della piccolina quest'anno l'ipo
prima le facciamo esplorare tutto mentre
in braccio e poi li metteremo a terra ad
esplorare tutto buona idea andiamo
se non avete lasciato un mi piace ancora
lasciate mi piace questo video perché
come sempre se raggiunge il 7 mila mi
piace sarà un altro video con la gattina
e se non avete visto lo scorso video in
cui circe prova quattro giochi
stranissime andate a vederlo dopo questo
video ma ora proseguiamo il nostro tour
guardia
un'altra pianta
è molto interessata sta osservando tutto
con gli occhi gigante guarda queste sono
delle olive
sente il rumore degli uccelli e quasi
un'altra pianta guerra
non si mangia non fare come berlino che
mangia tutto figuranti ed esplorare più
esplorare piccola al cirque andiamo
vediamo come reagisce
[Musica]
tutto
che carina
ma cosa
sta venendo verso di voi
lo schermo
piccola
del rumore
merlino e fa fuori ma non gliene frega
niente che ci sia circa il lager
canalino guardando meglio nel giardino
usando qualcosa da dietro le prime e
partita all'esplorazione
vediamo verso dove va
[Musica]
cosa c'è di buono lì che state ad ora
esplorando delle erbacce
no non si mangia questa un ora vanno
troppo e si che la piccola
eco merlino il sir c'e un pochino che
stanno abituando velo tantissimo berlino
con l'esempio donargli sedili no
la piccolina e sta onorando tutto
e facendo l'agguato al rame già
sembra che le piaccia tantissimo
giardino si sta divertendo un sacco
qualche cosa cosa
hai visto uno con oliva nel frattempo
berlino scarlino logiche sgranocchiato
il ticino
l'emelec news granocchia il rametto
si no
pezzo l'albero sull'albero così impari
anche a salire sugli alberi
[Musica]
si
è felicissimo ed isterico in giardino
[Musica]
dove corri berlino si sta godendo source
i gironi
albero di olivo
[Musica]
lo stesso mirror o
di piccoli no
no no non puoi rubare lo stecchino bene
e angolato berlino sta già guardando in
cagnesco
brava
sì ma prima c'è un sacco con i fili
d'erba sta guardando berlino no non puoi
rubargli l'ossicino dei troppo piccola
[Musica]
eccoli qua
berlino che circe
vuoi mangiare mi lasci delle scarpe
si sta divertendo un mondo
[Musica]
che carina
non ci arriva
ecco che carino tutto questo
[Musica]
circe sta esplorando il giardino
etico e questo
sta la piccola
cs città incastrando tempra un rosmarino
[Musica]
fine del tour over ci
ricordate che il pianista in casa
che grazie è tutto merito di circe
[Musica]